2人の男が、全く同じ日にビットコインのトレードを始めました。
1人は1日12時間もチャートに張り付き、
強気相場をがむしゃらに追いかけ続けました。
しかし昨夜、たった一度の「大口の罠」が、
彼の人生の貯金をすべて溶かしてしまったのです。
一方、もう1人の男はどうでしょう？
彼は家族と夕食を楽しみ、ぐっすり眠り、
翌朝5,000ドルの利益と共に目覚めました。
この差は運ではありません。システムの違いです。
1人は「カモ」にされ、もう1人は「真の勝者」となったのです。
多くのトレーダーが失敗するのは、
大口の仕掛けたゲームに乗らされているからです。
彼らは「買え」と言われた時に買わされていますが、
相場に罠がある時、あなたは単なる「獲物」です。
Trap Defence BTCは、
見えない罠を可視化してゲームを変えます。
私たちのエンジンは、機関投資家の操作が
あなたの資産を直撃する前に、その予兆を察知します。
勝率が味方するまで徹底して資金を守り抜く、
「生き残るための規律」をあなたに授けます。
これは、ハイリスクな相場を勝ち抜くための
究極のサバイバル戦略です。
そして今日、あなたはこの装備を無料で手に入れられます。
今すぐAcademyに参加し、
Trap Scoreの無料版を受け取ってください。
カード不要。無駄な煽りもありません。
あるのは、市場の生々しい真実だけです。
獲物になるのは、もう終わりにしましょう。
あなたが「相場の覇者」になるのです。ボットを起動し、
今すぐ無料アクセスを開始してください。